اهلا بك سيد الكسندر يعني مسؤول امريكي
همم قال ان القدر رؤوس منقسمون اليوم بشان
سنه هجوم شتوي واسع النطاق في اوكرانيا
هناك مخاوف لدى البعض من ان تحاول موسكو
مره اخرى السيطره على اكياس ما هي الاوضاع
اليوم وكيف تفسر مخاوف بوتين امس عندما
تحدث ان همم الوضع بالغ الخطوره في بعض
المناطق
الايام همم
المشاركه ورئاسه همم رئيس ودمير بوتين همم
وهو يلتقي مع
الاشخاص الاساسيين مال المسؤولين همم
وفيما يخص الاوضاع همم في همم بكره يعني
وفي دون باص همم
الاقامه معك هي دين الله
شيء طبيعي عنه رئيس بوتين الشعراء اه له
صعوبه الوضع هنا همم
هذا
التصريف كان مجرد اكيد
[موسيقى]
معالجه كل الصعوبات
توضع حاليا
متباينه داخل همم الحكومه والتساؤلات حول
قدره روسيا على القيام بهذه المرحله
الاحاديث خوله هذا الموضوع الله يعطي من
مصدر الغربي
وممكن نتصور ان هذا يعني لزرع الشقوق مثل
ما يحدث
في وسط الروسيه او اوساط دوليه بالنسبه
لي نحن نتحدث في روسيه عن الخلافات في
امريكا او خلافات اوكرانيا واوروبا والى
اخره انا لا اظن ان هناك الخلاف شيء ثاني
عنه ووضع بالنسبه
[موسيقى]
المستقبل المعارك هذا ووضع الاغاني
نعرف متى همم
يهاجم الجيش الروسي وحتى ربما وهناقصه
تكون المحاولات من الجانب الاوكراني لانه
المع معك متضاربه
ومصلا يقولون هناك مجموعات اوكرانيه تتسرب
في منطقه ليمار مثلا الا الشيء الثاني
الله صحيح انه الان ال- همم الجيش الروسي
يهاجم في منطقه دون بعض ولكن هذه الهجوم
تكتيكي وهو متواصل خلال الاجر هل يكون
هناك خطه جديده همم او هجوم في الاتجاه
همم الاخر فهذا لا نعرف وان لا اتوقع انه
مثلا رئيس بوتين او اي مسؤول اخر سوف يعلن
عن ذلك
خلي يكون
على صعيد او على مستوى العسكريين او
المسؤولين همم في الجيش هناك حديث عن همم
انتكاسات عسكريه كبيره لموسكو في الاشهر
الاخيره هناك انسحاب منطقه حركيه في شمال
شرق اوكرانيا ومدينه الجنوب يعني كيف
يتناول
ثاني يوم او الجنود تحديدا او كبار الجنود
هذه المعلومات هل تعتبر انتكاسات بالنسبه
لهم ام انتصارات واعاده تكتيك يعني كيف
ينظر من الداخل لهذه التحركات
اخرى انه كان هناك عده مراحل في هذه
الحركه
المرحله الاولى عندما همم هاجم
وووووها تقدم وجيش الروسي سريعا جدا
للمناطق حتى كيف خارقه
وهذا الله هذا لا همم لا يشتغل
فلذلك تراجع الجيش الروسي اولا من كيف
وخركوا في مع بعض هذا مين قرصان هذا
تقريبا
[موسيقى]
والمستمر الهجوم في دنباز هل نحن سندخل
الى مرحله اخرى خلال شهرين 30 فهذا هو
الموضوع المطروخ الان امام الجميع وانا
اتحدث عن ذلك عندما اقول انه وضع غامض ولا
نعرف بالفعل ما هي الخطه الروسيه بالنسبه
لجزئيه انت
ولذلك القدرات الروسيه
في المدفعيه وهذا الشيء الاساسي الله همم
باتريوت لم يغير شيء همم فبالتالي انه هل
يكفي القدرات الروسيه للهجوم الكبير خلال
همم في يناير او فبراير هذا هو السؤال وان
احنا ما فيش جواب عليه ولا واحد يعني ذلك
طيب شكرا جزيلا لك سيد همم
همم ازاز سكينه دبلوماسيه الروسيه السابق
انت معنا من موسكو شكرا جزيلا لك